One of the most common motions
we see in our everyday lives
is the path of an
object moving thrown
and moving through space.
Now, this type of motion
has a very famous name
called projectile motion.
And when we look at it, let's
introduce a coordinate system.
i hat and j hat.
Here's our y plus y-axis
and our plus x-axis.
Then, in order to understand
the kinematics of this motion,
we'd like to apply
Newton's second law.
So separately we'll
draw our object.
It has gravitational
force acting downward.
Remember our unit vectors
in the j hat direction.
And so when we write
our equations of motion,
f equals ma.
We have two
different directions.
In the j hat direction, we
have the gravitational force
downward minus mg.
And remember here that g is our
positive quantity, 9.8 meters
per second, and we have m a y.
Newton's second law equates
these two different things.
And that's-- we'll
write it like that.
So those two
quantities are equal.
And so our conclusion
is that the acceleration
is equal to minus g
in the y direction.
Now, likewise, keep
in mind that we
have our horizontal
direction as well.
And notice that we're
now assuming that there's
no horizontal forces.
In the real world, there can be
all types of air resistances.
But here, for the
simplicity of this model,
we have no horizontal forces.
So we have 0 equals m a x.
And so we have our separate
equation, a x equals 0.
Now, both of these equations
are equations that we've already
been working with in kinematics.
Here we have a
constant acceleration,
and here we have
zero acceleration.
So using the results that we
had earlier from integration,
we can write down the
equations of motion
in the y and the x directions.
First, we'll write the velocity.
Vy as a function of time is
equal to some initial value.
And because the acceleration
is negative, minus gt.
You can test your integration
technique to see that.
And the position as
a function of time,
remember, is just
some constant value.
This is our constant y nought.
And we have plus vy nought
t minus 1/2 gt squared again
doing integration.
Now, the horizontal
equation of motion,
the x(t), because there
is no acceleration
in the horizontal
direction, this
is a constant value given by the
initial value of the component
of the velocity
in the x direction
and the position x(t) is then
equal to some initial position
plus Vx nought t.
And so those are our
functions of time
for the components
of the velocity
and the components of position.
Now, for our particular
example, it's much easier.
Here we have X
nought equal to 0.
Notice that our object is
starting at the origin.
And so that tells us that
x as a function of time
is just Vx nought t.
I'm dropping the parentheses t.
Remember, that's not a product.
That's just a function of time.
And given this
fact, that tells us
that t is x divided
by Vx nought,
and now I can take
this value of t
and put it into our
vertical equation
and I get V y is some initial
value plus V y nought x over Vx
nought, substituting
for t, minus 1/2 gx
squared over V x nought squared.
When we described
projectile motion,
we had an equation describing
y as a function of t,
an equation describing
x as a function
of t-- the horizontal motion
and the vertical motion--
and here we have a
separate equation,
which is describing the
y as a function of x.
Notice there is no time
involved in this equation.
Now, let's try to
look at graphically
what we're seeing here.
So, for instance, when we look
at a plot of the motion of y
versus x, we can see the
vertical component going
up and down and we can see the
horizontal component moving
to the right while the object
is following this trajectory.
And this is a
parabolic trajectory
of y as a function of x.
Now, if we wanted to actually
plot out y as a function of t,
then here we can look
at the simulation
where we're just looking
at the y component
and you can see that that
motion too is a parabola.
However, what's
crucial to look at is
that it's y as a function of t
and not y as a function of x.
Finally, we can look at
the horizontal motion
and again recall that when we
looked at the trajectory as y
as a function of x, you can
see the horizontal motion
component.
Let's plot that separately,
x as a function of t.
And when we make
that plot, you can
see that this is just a
linear equation in time
where there is some
initial condition,
x nought, and so that's the
plot of x as a function of t.
And so we see three separate
representations of this motion.
y as a function of x, y
as a function of t, and x
as a function of t.